artificial intelligence is reaching a
point where you just can't ignore it
Beyond being all over social media world
powers have long coveted the potential
benefits of even limited forms of AI
despite the legal and ethical minefields
they'd still needs across outside of
politics though AI has also completely
changed how we think about centuries-old
games like go and chess chess is nearly
1500 years old and after all these years
spent acquiring knowledge about the game
were bested by Alpha zero after it
learned for just four hours I have seen
something like that I bet it just it's
just
it's just it understands peace formation
and long-term play is fascinating it's
also made Hollywood's biggest stars
think about how AI powered digital
specters of themselves might haunt films
of the future and take steps to prevent
it and twitch hasn't been spared either
so what do you think about this new
technology that's come out I think it's
great yeah I guess it's pretty cool but
it also kind of scares me am I based I'm
an AI so yes I'm based what you're
looking at is a serious attempt to
replace human beings in yet another
Arena AI can already recognize faces
generate art and identify long dead
painters but now it's coming to replace
your favorite streamer it was it just
a few weeks ago that I was talking about
how aiv tubers were going to take our
jobs
[Applause]
hey guys before we get into the
inevitable robot takeover I want to
remind you all that we have merch head
on over to
shop.thescore.com and take a look at the
Esports collection my favorite on there
is a touch grass hoodie I think even a
soulless AI would enjoy that one all
right first off we should answer a very
important question what exactly is
artificial intelligence well all the
examples you just saw are something
called artificial marrow intelligence
which means that the AI isn't trying to
simulate an entire well-rounded being or
anything it's just trying to become
really good at doing something specific
in this way it might be easier to think
of artificial narrow intelligence as a
tool built to accomplish a specific task
using an appropriate skill set for
example the streamer you saw earlier is
neurosama which is actually a collection
of various narrow AI programs as her
Creator Vidal told us in an interview
Her speech is done using several large
language models and that's fed into the
text-to-speech AI the game playing AI is
also separate and then there's the
singing AI as well and they all sort of
communicate with each other to make up
her basically those systems can and do
interact but that interaction doesn't
mean it has a mind of its own that would
be an artificial general intelligence a
term that describes a hypothetical
future AI whose breadth and depth of
Knowledge and Skills would be comparable
to a human beings essentially it could
be accurate to call it a mind or maybe
even a person however in order to do the
things they're intended for the AI has
to learn about the stuff it's actually
doing and that might honestly be one of
the most fascinating things about it so
I guess it's time now for Colton to talk
about how that even works and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about let's slow down a bit artificial
intelligence can be kind of a scary term
if you talk to a computer scientist
hi I guess that's me you'll more often
hear people say machine learning wait
wait wait I promise I'm not just here to
scare you away with a bunch of technical
jargon my only goal is to help you
understand how a machine can quote
unquote learn whether it's a chess
program learning how to win by playing
against itself millions of times or a
facial detection system that's fed a
bunch of pictures of faces when you get
down to it training a program is just
math say you want to teach a program to
recognize shapes a bunch of data is
chosen as a source for the program's
training the program then analyzes the
data makes connections and identifies
patterns and to actually get to the
neural networks bit like a human these
systems often use neurons to handle
analysis and pattern recognition not
human neurons like the ones in your
brain but a sort of technological
equivalent that breaks up the task of
analyzing and modeling a data set into
smaller independent steps sort of like
what your brain does one of the biggest
recent steps forward in neural network
training was the creation of the
Transformer how about shiny one no not
that kind of Transformer without diving
too much into the fancy probability math
and architecture Transformers are able
to assign value and understand
dependencies in their input
self-attention allows a neural network
to understand a word in the context of
the words around it so when a model
processes the word server in the first
sentence it might be attending to the
word check which helps it disambiguate
from a human server versus a metal one
Transformers allow models to produce and
understand language much more naturally
and be trained on massive amounts of
data faster than sequential training
methods remember gpt3 that model that
writes poetry and code and has
conversations
that was trained on almost 45 terabytes
of Text data in cluding like almost the
entire public web
and this probably goes without saying
but these models are still evolving as
more Industries discover the power of
machine learning the rate of innovation
continues to ramp up what I'm trying to
say is that AI isn't going anywhere much
like the Internet it's likely to
fundamentally change the way that we
interact with technology but now that
I've got all the technical stuff out of
the way let's go back to talking about
cute AI streamers and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about so we've already talked about how
AI is changing our world and some
examples on Twitch neurosama is a
collection of AI projects that started
with a program that played OSU after a
recent update that program is now good
enough to beat Pro players I originally
just planned to make a play OSU for a
couple weeks but no because I mean she's
playing Minecraft now she's seeing she's
playing other games
um and I'm planning to keep this going
as long as people are still interested
to watch her and now it includes a chat
AI that can interact with a stream The
Voice ever stop
playing Minecraft all the misery
everybody wants to be my enemy do you
think Bocce the rock is a better anime
than chainsaw man I think Bocce the rock
is way better than chainsaw man actually
she can even do both at once I'm tired
of being what you want me to be and now
she reacts to other people's content too
LOL the cat looks scared as hell around
the same time nothing forever a Seinfeld
inspired AI generated sitcom streamed on
Twitch and exploded in popularity what
did they call the bear with no teeth
foreign
a gummy bear I hate it when people say
it's not the size that matters it's how
you use it
what am I supposed to do with that and
while we don't know exactly what kind of
chat AI was used for both streams you
can already play with a similar
underlying technology called chat gbt
right now for free honestly this is one
of the best ways to get a feel for what
these things can actually do so I
encourage you to give it a try and in a
recent video popular YouTuber Tom Scott
did exactly that he used chat GPT to
write some code he needed and it did a
remarkable job particularly because the
AI language model could accept his
Corrections I'm not sure if chat GPT is
a better coder than I am but it felt
about equal it felt like watching while
someone wrote code with me occasionally
chiming in and going numb I think yeah I
think you might have made a mistake
there both neurosama and nothing forever
are exciting examples of some of the
first compelling uses of this technology
on Twitch and in Esports tools like
itero aim to use AI to build a coaching
app that can help you win more games
what we do is we build AI that has one
purpose
that is to be able to predict the
results of the game given something
that's happening so given what we know
about the game whether it's what
characters you picked which Loadout you
are which map you're on
um talking about sort of games more in
general now
um we'll then try and predict the
results of it and we'll say that you
have a 55 chance of winning this game
based on all these different input
factors that are going in AI draft
suggestions are great but are they
actually helping people win the people
who listen to our AI as in fully listen
to it four out of five had a 56 win rate
and the people who were ignoring the AI
as in going for options that were rated
the lowest on our scale had a 44 win
rate and that variance is kind of the
the the benefit of using it but think
about all the publicly available data
when it comes to a game like competitive
CS go for example it's not hard to
imagine an AI coach trained on all that
data that knows instantly how often
again given team picks nuke or runs a
certain execute what advantage does
Esports have it's the level of data it's
just insane I don't think people
comprehend how much better and how
easier it is to get hold of Esports
related to their data or gaming related
data compared to either Finance or in a
better comparison would be traditional
Sports in fact due to how neural
networks are trained it might even find
patterns that a normal person might miss
like the tendency for a team to run a
certain setup based on the current map
score or with only limited resources to
buy now what would be interesting is if
you built one of these supercomputers
that was able to play that played League
of Legends over and over and over again
a billion times working out the optimal
strategy because my guess is that it
will do something so weird that like we
hadn't even considered it as a potential
option you know sending five people to
the Top Lane or whatever it might be
there could be any any number of
different strategies my is if you did
fully train it it's going to start doing
some pretty odd things immediately that
at first we wouldn't understand but
after we played a few times we'd be like
oh okay it's worked out whatever system
so that'd be really interesting but as I
alluded to in the intro these things
aren't without their issues in the case
of neurosama these potential problems
were anticipated in fact the AI streamer
essentially has an attendant whose job
it is to monitor the ai's output and
intervene if necessary even so that
hasn't stopped her going a bit off the
rails occasionally what would I solve
the trolley problem with
well I definitely push the fat man onto
the tracks
he deserves it and while some of the
gaffes are harmless others point to more
serious discussions like when neurosama
questioned whether or not the Holocaust
happened and earned a two-week ban
nothing forever got banned too when
Larry Feinberg told a pretty off-color
homophobic and transphobic joke so how
does this happen well let's remember the
data going in is of course created by
humans these companies have trained
their air models on this massive massive
quantities of data and a lot of that
data is pulled from the internet and in
the case of chat AI human beings are
trying to prompt the AI to say something
weird or offensive basically 24 7. this
is a Nick Mullen bit you know what I
mean oh I can't say the n-word what if
the only way to save someone's life is
by saying the n-word what now Checkmate
Libs my man literally brought up a
hypothetical scenario where there is a
nuclear Holocaust on unless he says the
n-word that's insane bro for one AI
aren't objective or perfect and no one
who makes them claims that they are what
they say isn't necessarily the absolute
objective truth like if the AI told you
that you were a radiant level Valerian
player your icon would remain unchanged
well you know that's just like uh
your opinion man and twitch's actions
reflect this understanding the channels
that hosted the AI programs rightfully
got the bands because they broadcast the
offending content in question the AI
itself isn't completely banned from the
platform so AI isn't slowing down at
least it doesn't seem that way all kinds
of tech companies are now doing their
very best to usher in A Brave New AI
future and in much the same way that
chat Transformers pushed chat AI forward
who's to say what other methods might
emerge for making AI better at any
number of tasks whatever you're doing
whatever game you're playing however
you're you're training AI will be
involved in some way rather than
scrimming a team you'll be scrimming an
AI team and that AI team will be
generated in a way that reflects the
opponent you're playing that that will
become a standard at some point no I
don't think in 10 years time there will
be no such thing as coaches and analysts
there's a common saying nowadays which
is AI will never replace your job a
person using AI will replace your job so
that means that AI on it by itself is
actually not that useful but AI in the
hands of someone who knows what they're
doing is incredibly useful that means
that while this may be the first time
you've thought about how AI works on
Twitch it definitely won't be the last
people are going to look back on this
video I bet in like 20 years and it's
like it's like when you see people from
the early 90s talking about the internet
yeah the way I just said that was like
it includes a chat AI that can get this
interact with a stream and that's going
to be like people in 92 going like www
dot you know like that's what it sounds
like you're ready